[Musique]
donc atteint
béliers de personnes en plein festival
électro y compris des femmes cheveux au
vent et manches courtes aux côtés
d'hommes
l'événement s'est déroulé ici en
périphérie de ryad la capitale de l'un
des pays les plus conservateurs au monde
qui cherchent à s'ouvrir sur
l'international
sand storm est le plus grand festival de
musique de la région cette année plus de
700 mille personnes sont venues ici sur
quatre jours et environ 200 artistes
50% originaire de la région et 50 %
venant de l'étranger
nadal a biffé partie du collectif middle
east derrière ce festival hors normes
depuis que le royaume a donné son feu
vert à l'organisation de tels événements
ces jeunes saoudiens se sont emparés de
ce marché en pleine expansion
en 2017 le royaume est passé par de
nombreuses transformations donc les
fondateurs de mdl beast ont sauté sur
l'occasion pour organiser les plus gros
festivals de la région vous savez en
arabie saoudite la moitié de la
population a moins de 30 ans on a
énormément d'énergie et surtout on adore
la musique une musique interdite dans
les lieux publics il y a encore quelques
années à ryad l'homme qui a changé cela
le voici mohammed bin salman le prince
héritier c'est lui qui est à l'origine
des réformes sociales lancés dans le
royaume depuis 2016 son objectif
diversifier l'économie saoudienne ultra
dépendant du pétrole en développant
d'autres secteurs comme celui du
divertissement
alors une fois la nuit tombée les jeunes
profitent des nouvelles possibilités
ce café a ouvert en 2021
à refuge pour musiciens on supprime la
gérante
on voulait créer un hub pour les gens
qui partagent les mêmes idées qui sont
des artistes
on organise des sessions d'improvisation
avec ceux qui viennent et qu'ils peuvent
utiliser tous les instruments et
un lieu encore rares ryad car il n'y a
pas si longtemps la police religieuse
aurait demandé la fermeture de ce café
talent à un dj se souvenir de l'une de
leurs interventions lors d'un concert
qu'il avait organisée illégalement
en 2013 on a fait un rassemblement dans
le désert et on s'est fait attraper par
la police religieuse
c'était une mentalité différente vous
savez la musique était interdite le
mélange des sexes aussi quand tu te
faisait attraper c'eût été directement
embarqué par la police
il pouvait même te raser la tête
alors quand tu marches et ensuite dans
la rue tout le monde savait à celui ci
elle se fait choper par la police sur la
police mais cette police a largement
perdu en pouvoir ces dernières années à
mesure que la société l acquis de
nouvelles libertés
rim se souvient de son premier concert
public avec émotion elle s'y est rendue
avec son frère
je les regarde et je lui ai dit tu y
crois toi et moi frères et soeurs en
train de danser en arabie saoudite
devant un dj en train de mixer
sérieusement c'est vraiment quelque
chose j'en ai encore la chair de poule à
tous et saoudiens ont participé au
festival organisé par middle east ah si
les yazid ont même joué à l'un d'entre
eux le premier duo homme-femme saoudien
a mixé en public
on a joué à fond
pour montrer au monde que oui ici on
peut faire de la bonne musique est
complet
on peut mixer on a du goût on a des
artistes pas juste les clichés qu'on
peut entendre sur les saoudiens
[Musique]
aucun doute le royaume a bien changé ces
dernières années mais beaucoup reste
encore à faire selon les organisations
internationales de défense des droits de
l'homme ce qu'essaie de faire amnesty
international c'est de rappeler ce qui
est en train de se passer au même moment
ce qu'on ne voit pas c'est à dire l'une
des pires répressions de ces dernières
années selon les ong au moins 64
personnes seraient en prison dans le
pays pour avoir exprimé leur opinion
certains ont été libérés récemment mais
pour des raisons politiques affirme
cette représentante ces libérations ont
eu lieu à un moment où l'arabie saoudite
présider le g20 donc à un moment où la
communauté internationale regarder de
près le pays mais dès que ça a été
terminé il y a eu à nouveau des
arrestations et des procès de militants
modernisation ne rime pas avec plus de
liberté d'expression en arabie saoudite
tous nos entretiens dans le royaume ont
d'ailleurs dû se faire en présence d'un
employé du ministère des médias face aux
déclarations d'amnesty international
les autorités n'ont pas répondu à une
demande de commentaire